Estefanía Gracias por acompañarnos
Hola Omar buenas noches y por supuesto
Ya empezaron estos importantes juegos
para todos los deportistas para más para
los más de 4000 atletas así como usted
lo mencionó que se están dando cita aquí
en Asunción por los próximos 13 días de
estos de estas justas Este es el evento
digamos menos
conocido menos consolidado del ciclo
olímpico tenemos eventos como los juegos
centroamericanos que se disputan desde
1926 o los Juegos Panamericanos que
están desde el 51 que trae de nuevo esta
justa para tratar de consolidarse y
conseguir un espacio dentro del ciclo
olímpico
Así es sumar Esta es lado se daba
adición en la que se disputan estos
juegos suramericanos y poco a poco ha
ido cogiendo fuerza su organizador o de
Sur ha buscado que los deportistas se
motiven Y que además las delegaciones
los diferentes comités Olímpicos Pues
por supuesto traigan a las elecciones
tipo a como se dice o como comúnmente se
les llama qué va a pasar en esta edición
pues van a haber cupos o se están
disputando cupos mejor ya para los
Juegos Panamericanos de Santiago 20:23
recordemos que por la pandemia este
ciclo olímpico está un poco corto y las
competencias están un poco más ajustadas
en lo que tiene que ver con el tiempo
son en total 24 disciplinas deportivas
que van a jugarse cupos a los Juegos
Panamericanos entenderán los Juegos
Panamericanos son las últimas justas
deportivas previas a los Juegos
Olímpicos Por ende los atletas tendrán
que buscar también sus marcas sus
posiciones dentro de estas competencias
estamos hablando de todas las
disciplinas acuáticas una pasión
carreras natación artística aguas
abiertas
clavados el deporte olímpico Rey
atletismo balonmano ciclismo entre otras
unas por marcas unas por posiciones pero
como le digo ya los atletas ven estos
juegos suramericanos como un paso
importante para muchos es el primero
para países como Colombia Venezuela
Ecuador ya es el segundo después de
juegos bolivarianos ya desde ayer
comenzaron estos juegos y hoy también ya
hay muchos clasificados a juegos
panamericanos a Santiago 20:23
qué Brasil y Argentina suelen dejar o
reservarse a sus grandes figuras y no
traerlas a este evento es esta la
situación en esta oportunidad o si han
presentado unas delegaciones fuertes
estos dos que son los llamados a hacer
los grandes animadores
mire justamente y siguiendo la línea de
lo que venimos hablando un equipo como
Brasil que en diferentes campeonatos por
ejemplo el año pasado llevaban hasta su
selección c en estos juegos
suramericanos vinieron con todas las de
la ley como saldríamos decir para estos
juegos estamos hablando le voy a dar
ejemplos Ana María Acuña Ana Marcela
Acuña perdón de Brasil viene de ser
campeón a olímpica en Tokio en aguas
abiertas y además recientemente llegó de
budapeciendo campeona mundial Esta es
una figura y que por supuesto es
favorita ganar la medalla de oro
Estefanía baluccini que acaba de tener
una jornada de oro fantástica para
Brasil en la natación carreras Leonardo
de deus por dar otros nombres también
para Brasil ahora en lo que tiene que
ver con Argentina argentina se ha
especializado y se ha convertido en una
selección favorita en lo que tiene que
ver con los deportes de Conjunto es el
caso de rugby en sus dos ramas tanto
masculina como femenina hockey sobre
césped Así que vienen con sus equipos a
con sus figuras y esperamos Por supuesto
que esto enriquezca un campeonato que
termina siendo y que ya está también
comenzando a hacer muy importante para
el ciclo olímpico de Suramérica y de los
países cercanos también pero si la ha
tenido un extraordinario arranque
dominando el medallero en esta primera
jornada y quería preguntarle pensando en
el resto del programa del calendario
puede pensarse que sustentable esta
ventaja tan Arrolladora que ha tenido
Brasil en este comienzo
mire justamente desde que llegamos lo
hemos hablado con diferentes colegas le
voy a dar dos datos entre atletismo y
natación se disputan aproximadamente 90
entre 100 medallas en natación son
aproximadamente entre 50 y 56 de las
cuales en un 95% están estimadas que
lleguen a las manos de los brasileros
estamos hablando por supuesto de
medallas de oro en ese caso estamos
hablando que la ventaja de Brasil es
considerable hoy por lo menos en la
pasión
Brasil Tuvo una Arrolladora jornada
tanto así que la ventaja que usted misma
menciona es producto de una jornada
brillante para Brasil en natación
definitivamente sus protagonistas son
campeones Olímpicos en bienes el
protagonistas mundiales y está muy lejos
muy lejos del nivel de otras elecciones
el caso de Argentina el caso de Colombia
El mismo Venezuela e incluso Paraguay
Así que Brasil para mí es el favorito y
seguramente será el campeón de estos
juegos suramericanos
Muchísimas gracias estefa